A while passed as we talked
About proteins and their many roles
In dynamic systems,
We have given many examples of these roles, including hormones and antibodies,
Maintain cellular structure and signal,
And others. And actually, the ability of proteins to do
With all these things
Is a by-product of its structure.
So, the idea we will discuss in this video
It is a structure
Protein structure, so we understand it and know its value.
Here, for example, we have a hemoglobin molecule,
Here it is
This molecule
Consists of 4 polypeptide chains.
Two of them are made up of 141 amino acids,
The other two chains consist of 146 amino acids,
Thus, the molecule is composed of a total
Amino Acid.
But as you can see, their order is never random,
On the contrary, it is properly organized
For the appropriate function, that is
In this case the oxygen transfer,
Transferring oxygen through red blood cells.
Accordingly, we ask a question which is
How the structure of hemoglobin,
Or other proteins
Which owns different functions?
The answer is short
We have different layers or different grades
The structure of proteins.
The first degree is
Primary structure.
The initial structure that is actually just arranged
amino acids.
Do you remember when we talked about
Transfer RNA messenger nuclear code to the ribosome,
Where the transporter RNA then comes with amino acids,
She puts them one by one and ties them together?
All these things occur in the translation step,
Is actually the step of building the initial structure of proteins.
In other words, DNA synthesis
Are determined
Order of amino acids
Which in turn form the primary structure.
Arrangement
Acids
amino acids.
Let us now move on to the second level of structure,
An answer to the next question as long as the initial structure
Are just ordering amino acids,
What makes this polypeptide take different forms
Allow him to do the necessary jobs?
the level
The second level of structure,
Known as the secondary structure of protein,
Secondary structure,
Is the result of infrastructure interactions.
Result of interactions
Infrastructure Interactions
For protein,
As a result of protein infrastructure interactions,
I will give you more than an example.
I have some examples here.
As you can see, we have a series here
Polypeptide Series,
Amino acids linked to each other
Through peptide links.
Here,
Here we have a link with Pptidi
Link Pptidi,
Between carbonyl carbon and nitrogen,
This is also a second link between carbonyl carbon
Nitrogen, this is a third link.
This series,
The polypeptide series, you can imagine
They are complementary to the bottom,
Or spin and then return for example.
But despite the detour,
Note that polypeptide linkages themselves are repeated
Nitrogen-carbonyl carbon, peptide bond,
Nitrogen-carbonyl carbon,
Link Pptidi,
But the extra thing that appears with us,
Is the interactions between the same protein infrastructure.
On the idea, I did not elaborate in the drawing of side strings,
I just wanted to symbolize it with a letter R, because it's important to have interactions
Between the two sides of the infrastructure is clear.
As you can see, we have nitrogen here,
We know that it is electrically negative.
Thus, it will emit electrons from hydrogen,
Hydrogen becomes a partial positive charge.
Since oxygen is also electrically negative,
Will have a partial negative charge,
After it takes electrons from the carbon.
As a result, oxygen and hydrogen
They will be attracted to some,
They form the hydrogen bond
Which we know.
The same idea will be repeated here,
Here and here.
In the end, these two chains
Will be a form
Known
A form known as a beta plate.
plate,
Beta plate.
If we go here, you will see that we have another beta plate,
But if you focus, you will notice a difference between them.
In this case, the link is between nitrogen and alpha carbon,
Which we see here,
Alpha carbon is associated with carbonyl carbon,
So we have nitrogen, carbon alpha, carbonyl carbon,
Here again we have the same sequence, nitrogen,
Carbon alpha, carbon carbon, nitrogen,
Carbon carbon, carbon carbon.
Therefore, this plate is known as a parallel beta plate,
Because, as you have seen, it is made up of the two infrastructure series
They are interacting with each other
By forming links in the same direction,
Hence its name
Parallel plate.
This was the parallel situation, but when we look at this situation,
We note that the order is
Nitrogen, carbon alpha, carbonyl carbon,
From the left,
On the right, the order is Carbon Carbon,
Alpha carbon, nitrogen.
Carbon carbonate, alpha carbon, nitrogen.
Thus we are going in the opposite direction.
And actually, what I've done is
I copied the first structure and its heart,
So you notice that it is reversed.
But even so,
Hydrogen bonds are still between
Partially positive limb
Of the nitrogen-hydrogen bond
Specifically hydrogen
And partially oxidized oxygen.
still
Hydrogen bonds are still present,
The two basic structures are still parallel,
But the difference is that they are going in the opposite direction.
Therefore, you know this structure
With an inverse parallel beta plate.
plate
Parallel reverse beta plate
Another type of protein structure.
Here we have a third type,
Note that the infrastructure in it
Come in the form of a screw,
Where we have hydrogen bonds
Between different classes,
For the same pulp.
As we have said before, we have oxygen here with a charge
Partially negative,
This hydrogen has a partially positive charge,
Thus forming a hydrotherapy bond.
We can also have a link here,
Until we are formed in the end,
Spiral structure,
Known as
Alpha Screw.
Thus we conclude that all these
The interactions that you get inside
The structure of the protein
Is what constitutes the secondary structure.
But we have not finished yet,
Because there are still side strings.
Some of these chains are afraid of water,
Thus, if it is present in aqueous solution,
They are trying to escape from it and confront it.
Therefore, it is possible to form these side chains
Hydrogen bonds with other chains.
In short, you'll get some reactions in one way or another.
This method may be forming links
Sulfur dioxide,
Or covalent bonds with second side chains.
We will go into all these details
Later, God willing,
But now our goal is
To know that the triangular structure
For protein
Is the result of side-chain interactions.
Result of interactions
Result of side chain interactions.
If we imagine, for example,
This basic structure I draw here,
We can have
Set of side chains,
Symbolized by letter R,
Afraid of water,
As mentioned above, if we have water in the vicinity of protein,
We have to imagine the three dimensions,
How can these chains form proteins in a way that allows them to hide from water.
In contrast, if these strings are polarity
And loving water, we will imagine that it will form protein
In a way that allows it to be in the face of water.
Or we can have two chains,
We will mark the first R1,
R2,
May be combined by a hydrogen bond,
Or ionic association, for example.
We have different types of links
Possible between the two chains,
We will separate this in a subsequent video, God willing.
Let's go back to the big picture now, a protein made up of a single polypeptide
It will have elementary structure, secondary structure,
And triangular structure.
But some proteins are more than polypeptides,
Such as the hemoglobin we talked about at the beginning of the video,
In this case, we have an additional structure, the quaternary structure.
When we speak of the quartet,
The quartet,
We are talking about the way they are gathered
Different polypeptide chains
To form the largest vessel.
In short,
Multiple interactions
Between multiple strings
Interactions
Multiple interactions
Between multiple strings
Which numbered four in the case of hemoglobin.
I hope this video has helped you more
In knowing the value of protein structure
Which is really a wonderful area of ​​study.
The more we understand the more many ways
In which protein can be synthesized,
The more we can understand the more
DNA Translation Process
For primary structure,
And to discover more how these proteins work,
How can it be reformed,
And even make use of them in different roles from their main roles.
This area is indeed a vast and fascinating area for studies and research.